that's some breaking news to bring you
in relation to the south african variant
and we are hearing in the last few
moments that surge testing is to be
deployed in redbridge that is uh
an east london borough we're being told
that nhs test and trace
is providing additional testing and
genomic sequencing in targeted areas
within the ig-1 and ig-6 postcode areas
and small parts
of the ig-5 and ig-7 postcode areas this
is following the identification
of two confirmed cases of the variant
first identified in south africa
south africa although the two are not
thought to be
linked they are both self-self-isolating
their contacts have been identified and
there are no links between these cases
of saying
the cluster of cases recently identified
in the south
london area they're asking anybody over
the age of 11
who resides or works in those postcodes
to
come forward for a covert 19 pcr test
whether or not
they are showing symptoms that is
following on
from two cases of south african variant
in the redbridge east london borough